bene da tutti ragazzi è vero che questo
video siamo tornati su dei maroon 99 89
quanti 9 detto chi se ne frega buona
visione
eravamo rimasti che abbiamo fatto fuori
quel bellimbusto abbiamo preso coso che
la porta
diciamo che siamo ancora non ho tempo i
traditori o raggiungere livello
superiore va bene come si piglia
ascensore madonna mi l'ansia che mette
burqa giorno potrei picchiarti e farti
fuori picchiando t e infatti lo farò
l'ho dimenticato che i pugni gli sto
tizio sono c'è questo qua e iron man
tira un cazzottone caduti per terra va
bene me ne vado portate che non arrivi
altra gente il tipo si alzato
aspettavano ripicche ciao mi piaceva un
sacco sto gioco no perché veramente dal
primo episodio notato che mi dà proprio
soddisfazione dichiara liso andiamo
avanti open giorno
porca vacca un morto fortissimo
importante che non si alzi allora credo
che il virus in qualche modo vale a
deteriorare un po la carne del della
gente ce li vedo che sono un po zecchini
tizi però
in che senso ha devo disattivarla qua
deposita il campione di più se ne vanno
sicurezza mi lascia lì pollux si onlus
pollux combinaguai dimentico sempre chi
sei giorno sono contento dice alzato
però stai un progetto ancora come preso
mi ha fatto malissimo
non pensavo riuscisse a prendermi vado
da meno lo meno veloce a cartoni in
bocca bravo a posto delle pistole non lo
usiamo legname vasta dove ho capito lo
ha lasciato lì parco lemonia ragazzi che
figata sostanza porca vacca sono così al
sun tutti tutti in piedi
posso uscire dalla porta per favore
fatemi uscire dalla porta non posso
ancora c'è la struttura perché mi serve
il pollux maledizione se riesco a fare
il giro di qua perché prima che se lo
prendo poi non riescono a veloci a prima
porta prima portata porta a porta a
porta
mamma mia ragazzi nostra e vabbè ma si
alzano tutti che vita orribile non avere
un apre la porta e vabbè allora gli
spariamo giorno 2 comandiamo bene per di
proiettili bravo chi siamo
mena mena a meno ancora benissimo c'è un
quadro cui solamente prima sbarazzarmi
ho capito un po di proiettili che non ho
niente con quali proiettili man alimena
li abbiamo il mio forte noi proietti
ragazzi non posso sbarazzarvi abitano
nei proiettili
apri apri rai aprite va bene che li ha
portati a degli stati uniti
ecco il presidente ci siamo ragalo ra
vecchia macchina spiega che teoricamente
posso salvare la partita no sos percio
sperato o il computer nascosto
bellissimo illumina l'oscurità e non ci
sarà tempesta da cui lui non possa
salvarti possono giocare a warcraft a
ragazzi bisogna trovare un modo per
sbloccare porte o robe del genere però
in questo caso
permettetemi non funziona va bene
illumina l'oscurità e non ci sarà
tempesta qui non posso trovato un
indovinello eni eni gas e luce una bella
siringhe na sa può stare meglio
teoricamente non sa pinto raffigurante
l'eroe greco giasone in possesso del
golden fleet l'uscita di curare
qualsiasi ferita va bene castor ma chi è
che schiaccia dei food day
ma lo sapete che c'è qualcuno che
schiaccia dei di pupazzi e non riesco a
capirne il motivo sembra essere io
stai calmo senti sai mica quale la
password può capire cosa mettere devo
mettere un codice e pest asus
forse devo mettere le di iniziale di
ogni dio può essere con levità del sole
eccolo qua ha illuminato il futuro ecco
da questo qua che illumina illumina
apollo devo scrivere apollo nel computer
la password la passo del mio canale
ragazzi apollo non provate ci sto
scherzando
ap la pillole sta che è stata schiera fa
schifo
faccio credo credo che siano gli stessi
tasto guardando la mia tastiera e sto
facendo schiacciando i tasti della sua
apollo e giusto no porco demonio questa
la a
a destare al campo c'e dal dl apollo
porco schifo ma cerco su google come
diceva paul in greco apollo in greco se
scrive o cristo in greco antico si
scrive o la madonna e bordello o demoni
in greco a dio apollo in senso di a
volte ci ho messo tuara scriverà pollin
greco al cup
un altro non hanno importanza le ferite
subite il suo viaggio non finirà mai dai
cheppallle veramente le ferite da questo
secondo vita dalla capacita di come
qualsiasi finita golden fleet mi devo
scrivere in greco golden please join ha
finito di alzato lo zio iniqua non
citerò mancato premorto prendi il
campione virus corri corri devo andare a
prenderlo 18 st intanto styling ma si
alzano tutti lo so io
ma si sa il fa tutto dunque bella sta
roba degli dèi però un po complicato per
una persona che c'è un cervello solo
tipo me allora teoricamente dovremmo
andare io finiti micol ma quindi se non
prendo
l'altra arma cielo veramente nel
deretano quindi prendila allora
teoricamente sennò c'è questo qui non è
vero che si alza gente però mondadori
nelle giu stai giù cartoni modo ma dai
ma dai ma non ci credo ma dai non devono
morire che poi dei rischi per tutti
degli dei colpi per uccidere una persona
che ha fruttato ok l'altro in tutto
questo passi è chiusa la porta quindi
come la riapro scusami anno ma
teoricamente adesso devo passare da si
apre il coah perfetto giorno console
telecamere sicurezza della base che
posso entrare da qui ho fatto il giro
praticamente giusto che figo che figata
sostanza molto carina pure eccolo poi
luis recuperato a posto che stava dietro
il terminale quindi bene bene così
windows xp terminale dell'archivio è
bloccato prendi sta roba
va a morozzo sta schiattando di tutto
questo mi non devo farmi toccare da
nessuno
grandi e faccio schifo
meno bene bene per avere veloci lo
portarono i fogli si è fatto già fatto
ai lava la faccia o magari ce l'ho fatta
a fare un bel pezzo ragano male
non male mi fa piacere che i pavimenti
siano tutti puliti e non sporchi di
sangue sotto l'ascensore scena la cut
scenes va bene
porca vacca intel atom io faccio
veramente schifo come persona ho
imparato anche all'altra gente prima di
non parlare troppo
c'è l'incredibile non ci credo ma perché
c'è un comando un deficiente
niente fa fuori la gente lui ammazza le
persone come se niente fosse cibo va
bene non mi merito nulla della mia vita
ma la politica iniziata perfetto
abbandona il centro ricerca vado porro
c'era la porta di entrata era quella di
anni soprano video tornare semplicemente
su ok
teoricamente non credo che tutto questo
sia facile
teoricamente alla stanza è vicino devo
solo andare avanti così ora destra ma
poi cosa dice che non sarà così facile o
due proiettili ripeto quindi sono stati
faccio schifo
corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri corri corri non c'e nessuno
ce ne sono certo non c'è nessuno
incredibile
e infatti lady che insomma morto
le faccio aprì la porta ma come tieni
duro
no no fermo nono colpi non colpi sono
colti muoiono corpi sono due o cristo ma
quando sei ancora più piccolo dai dai
dai due minuti possono esistere tanto
questo con lo picchiava johor alcol e
moglie c'è altra gente cavalcano forza
picchiare tutti picchio tutti i miti a
tutti vai a mio zio
vai due minuti così penso sia
difficilissimo ragazzo però ci provo
metal detector ai picchiarlo stare fermo
no rai annuncia farò mai
se vi rendete conto che sono troppi di
minuti porco schifo l'ho picchiato il
tempo aiuterà a prima porta per l'amor
di dio non ce la farò mai
non era impossibile non può farlo felice
di giri tipo valentino rossi
ti prego pochissimi col vino dovuto fare
a pugni una donna del mio
che ansia arrivo da me lo meritavo ma
come va fuori
ho preso a cazzotti ma maglie e giuseppe
giulietti
va bene ragazzi concluso che questo
episodio di the ma spero vi sia piaciuto
molto bello come gioco comunque mi piace
tanto e cioè proprio carina mimando un
bacino
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciata dalla
campagna minuto molto importante ultimi
vent aggiornati sito che escono lasciato
un bel mi piace e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo vita beh ragazzi
[Musica]